Why don't more people care about my
thing.
It's unbelievable the way the rest of
you just blissfully live your lives,
unconcerned with the real issues of this
world.
After all,
take any aspect of your life.
My group would agree that my thing is
the most pressing thing about it.
Don't you all realize how serious this
is?
I mean,
let's not even talk about people with a
different opinion of my thing.
The fact that they don't agree with my
fax means that they're willfully
ignoring the facts.
No,
I'm talking to you.
The one with no dog in this fight.
Really your the one to blame here.
You keep talking about your thing and
going on about that,
but you have to realize by not taking
action on my thing,
you're perpetuating the problem in
action is action and you've done quite
enough for ready,
I guess silly me for thinking that other
people would actually be logical and
reasonable for a change and realize that
my thing should be as important to them
as it is to me.
It just breaks my heart.
Why don't more people care about my
thing?
Okay.